[Music]
on today's show we
talk to a young mom who's trying to
figure out how to communicate
weight and body image and food
challenges to her young daughter
we talk to a wife who's struggling to
connect
with her first responder husband we talk
about the differences between boundaries
and ultimatums stay tuned
[Music]
yo yo yo this is john with the dr john
delony show
so glad you joined us taking real calls
from real people about your life your
mental health your relationships your
kids
that trauma good stuff
tough stuff all of it thank you so much
for joining us we're so glad you're here
if you want to be on the show if you've
recognized man life got sideways on you
and you got nobody else to call
give us a shout at 1-844-693-3291
it's 1-844-693-3291
or you can go to johndaloni.com ask
ask fill out the form if you call us
leave a message
leave a detailed message like it's 1985
and you got an answering machine
leave a message at the beep and let us
know what's going on
and we will try to get you on the show
we've got
we've got callers from all over planet
earth we get
letters and cards and notes from all
over creation it's exciting it's awesome
join us on the show it'd be fantastic
hey we got a whole crew
in there man so we got a bunch of people
pinch-hitting this morning we've had
all kinds of wildness in people's lives
personal lives and so
we would appreciate your prayers and
your thoughts for folks but we have a
whole
whole booth we got 50 people back there
it's awesome so i'm waving to everybody
it's good to see everybody
the original og mentor of mine bob the
radio
i can't call you radio god because it's
probably not a nice way to say it but
did i tell you i was getting my haircut
the other day bob and
all like i kept hearing your voice but i
thought it was in my head
and it wasn't it was you were i was
listen they were playing this radio
station
in the place where i was getting my
haircut and your voice it was
giving me peace in my soul man oh you're
so good to me
listen to that can you just tell me
something tell me
like just a piece of good news the good
news is that uh
we're gonna be okay listen to that guy's
taking care of us
and we can trust in him because even if
he doesn't deliver us from the fire
we're still going to trust him and man
he's still god
dad can you tell me tell me something
negative
in that voice oh ah
it's not gonna get us canceled no no no
you uh
you took my notebook off my desk
i've been trained over a number of years
to find people like you
if you don't bring it back i will find
you and i will kill you
now listen when i didn't know what was
happening
in the radio world that was the guy
being like
okay um so i wouldn't say it like that
i would uh let's try it this way the
most positive
hey i'm so glad everybody's back there
caitlin ben everybody man
engineers everybody's hanging out so
it's so good to have everybody
all right let's get to the phones let's
go to meg in pensacola hey meg what's
going on
hey um i'm so happy to talk to you and i
just want you to know that whatever
chaos y'all are dealing with there today
it really put me at ease to hear it
happening in the background
so thank you meg listen
the what what you guys hear what you
hear on a finished podcast
is so thoroughly edited i i'm
like a terrible driver and they'll send
me driving for
two and a half hours and then they will
snip like 11 minutes of that drive and
make it look like everybody's having a
peaceful time in the car
um so i'm not a great driver so listen
we're all
having a rough go of it so it's good to
talk to you
so what's up man how can i help so my
question is
um at its court should i be doing more
to protect
my young daughter from unhealthy ideas
about food and body image
um or maybe is this something where i'm
kind of overreacting because of my own
history with body insecurity
um so wow hold on
i've got a young daughter i've got
my own body dysmorphia issues
i've got my own yeah man you are you are
reading my mail on this one so
um walk me through tell me tell me about
your journey here tell me what's going
on
i know this is probably got a specific
issue you're dealing with
yeah so i have a two-year-old daughter
so she's very young okay um
and the context is my husband and i
moved back up to live close to my family
last year
and we embarked on this crazy journey of
uh
buying a house and remodeling it while
we're living in it because we're nuts
yeah so while we're doing that my
my family has very kindly stepped in to
help us with child care
so right now my grandmothers are are
basically providing
day-to-day care for my daughter and i
work remotely so i go with her
to their house every day while they
babysit so that's kind of the situation
that we're in but the background
is that um i've struggled with body
image issues
as long as i can remember i think i
started dieting when i was
11 or 12. and who gave you that message
uh it's so it's very much part of the
the kind of like women in my family
there's one of my grandmothers in
particular that i would kind of label
like the matriarch of our family
has a very strong voice when it comes to
um what fatness means and what certain
foods
are about like the morality of of how
you eat foods being good and bad and
people being good and bad as a result of
what they eat
right um so that was a big trope
and i have some really vivid memories of
being a kid and it just like
it hitting home like i remember i
remember sitting in a captain bees
like uh eating you know like fried fish
and
french fries as you do um and my
grandmother pointing out
uh a person across the way who was
really heavy
and basically commenting on how
disgusting it was to watch them eat when
they were eating the same food that i
was eating
um and then like in the second breath
like telling me to go get a refill of my
coke
you know to get my money's worth so just
that kind of um
that kind of contradictory message about
food where food is something that
that we you know my family uses to love
people with you know we
they they want to cook for you they want
to bake for you and that's how we show
love and how we celebrate things but
it's also how we we punish
ourselves i think and how we um you know
it sort of
has become like a moral code you know
you you express your ability to like
you're self-controlled
you know by by not eating certain things
so okay
i can't stop you there you just you just
articulated
i think one of the great
mysteries slash great challenges
of our time and we've watched it with
covid we've watched it with weight
issues we've watched it with health
issues we've watched it with
religious and morality issues which is
how do you hold on to something that
has hurt or damaged people and not throw
the whole thing away
at the same time right exactly how to
not go to war with it
so the irony of sitting in a captain d's
which man i can get sideways into
captain d's
but there is no there is no
vegetarian or keto version of ca you go
to captain d's to destroy your soul
right that's why you go there absolutely
and when you're in there you know
what you're doing isn't great and so
instantly your body goes to war to make
sure
you can feel safe in that environment
and so you have to point out
others right you got to point out thems
and you've got to create a space between
you and them
you know what you're doing is stupid but
at least it's not that right
and we do that everywhere so it sounds
like your
grandmother is dealing with her own
demons all the time and she does what we
all do which is
make sure she can have some
psychological space between her and
everybody else
and how you do that you teach your kids
and you teach your grandkids
right that they whoever they is is not
us
right man that's hard and now you're
what you're watching it happen to your
two-year-old
yeah kind of so i'm starting to see um
you know because i'm actually in the
house
where where you know she's being taken
care of and i don't want to like
pinpoint this one grandmother
no hey it's it's a cultural idea let me
tell you this let me tell you this
and one of my favorite most
extraordinary people in my life
as was my grandmother on her
literally on her deathbed
she is taking her last breaths right
um in a bed that she got in in a
hospital never came out of
yeah she was had lost her sight
she was in constant pain and i went to
visit her
and we she was a hilarious lady always
telling jokes always clowning on people
that's where i got my sensei like she's
a riot
but i'm holding her hand she's looking
up i'll never forget this and she said
hey i know you can't see me under this
sheet
i haven't weighed this this i haven't
had this weight
since high school oh my god you know
what i mean that
that machine that engine was still
running
like yeah hey i'm my body's wasting away
but man you should see the number on
that scale right so it's not your
grandmother it is
in the air we breathe right right i can
work out like
crazy do all the right things and then i
walk by
the mirror and i'm like really
you know you know what i mean yeah and
so yeah
i'm with you 100 so absolutely not
on your grandmother but at the same time
how do we
how do we not let our kids like breathe
this poisonous air and at the same time
be grateful for the folks that
taught us how to breathe right right and
that's the thing i mean i
she's bending over backwards to help me
right now she's and she's
feeding my daughter during the day you
know which i'm grateful for
and so i you know i love her i'm
grateful for her
but i'll hear bits and pieces of things
that remind me of like
all the stuff that i've spent the last
you know i don't know however many years
picking apart and trying to like uh
reconcile with
you know being spoken to my daughter or
um give me an example of that
so something like um so
so this is she was actually talking to
me but my daughter was in the room
so one day she brought lunch for us and
she made a cobbler and i don't mean
she didn't make me like a ramekin of
cobbler she made an entire
sheet pan of coffee like a bathtub yeah
that's right yeah as you should make
cobblers but go ahead
as as one does right and she said all
right now you know you have to take this
home with me today and i said oh man i
really
i really don't need to take it home and
she said yes you have to i said no ma'am
you know i
i really shouldn't have that much sugar
and she looked at me and said well
you're just going to have to learn some
self-discipline
and she's giving and my daughter's
sitting there eating you know in her
high chair and i know that she's not
reading the subtext of that right yet um
but you know she was like so here's what
your daughter's reading okay
and and this isn't i think this is the
way forward for you here okay
um your daughter your right is not
picking up she she'll hear the word
self-discipline she'll absorb that right
and there's a there's a
consequence of that and there's actually
some truth to that and that's where this
the whole thing gets so messy
there is some self-discipline and how do
you balance self-discipline with
hospitality
and with morality and values all of that
gets messy
what your daughter's gonna absorb
literally into
her gene expression literally into her
physiology and chemistry
is the tension is
the mom's whole
essence energy everything about mom just
got tense when she held this cobbler
everything got tense in this
relationship between grandmother
and my mom does that make sense that's
what she'll absorb
and then what will happen is she will
begin to create her own narratives as to
why there is tension
right some of it will be clear to her
because it's about food some of it will
be clear to her
about a and b and c and then some of it
she'll just make up
right so when you've got a two-year-old
who's
just eating and being fed great if you
hear your grandmother which she probably
won't tell a two-year-old
honey i'm gonna put a pizza there on the
floor we don't eat pizza
right she's not gonna do that to a
two-year-old so some of this you're
gonna have to recognize
is your demons that you're bringing to
this conversation
right some of this is and that's where
you got to make sure
that you're not passing that on to your
daughter you're angst
through grandmother right some of this
is going to be
you say hey thank you for this cobbler
thanks and you take it because how held
your grandmother 70
80 right um yeah we're not gonna go to
war over this i'm gonna take the cobbler
i'm gonna put in the trash i'm not gonna
eat it
right i will show yourself i'll show you
self-discipline i'm gonna take it i'm
putting garbage
right and we're not gonna have any more
conversations about it if that's
this is gonna sound weird if that's the
way to to show your grandmother respect
in a moment
and also uphold your values and what you
know to be right about the way you need
to sleep and take care of your body
so be it right yeah and if she comes
back
and says oh two weeks later did you eat
that whole cobbler
you can say no ma'am i couldn't finish
that whole cobbler like i've got to have
self-discipline
and then the conversation's over she
doesn't have to know that discipline for
you meant but in the trash
right so you do the things that keep you
well and those things
some would call that peacekeeping and
that's a whole other conversation right
um i call that just being respectful
right
so if my grandmother let's say made a
joke about those guys that drink beer
like well that's just those trashy guys
that drink beer i might just smile
i might say grandmother it's not because
of the beer
i'm not gonna then launch into a tirade
about how i don't think drinking beer is
bad and i have beer with my
does that make sense like so there's
just those boundaries right
i think for you um the biggest
impact you can make on your daughter is
how you
interact with food how you interact with
her how you interact with
self-discipline
in your home when it's y'all too
does that make sense yeah yeah and
that's gonna be hard because my guess is
you're still healing i still am healing
most of the people who have had
challenges with food with body image
are on a forever healing journey does
that make sense
totally and then i'll tell you this one
hard boundary
there is gonna come a season when your
grandmother's gonna say something that
you gotta step in on
with your kid when it comes to food when
it comes to body image you have to step
in on that
and that may mean you end up with
different child care
and so to answer your original original
question
yeah there may come a moment and i think
it's important for you and your husband
to have those boundaries pre-established
because it's real easy for them to go
one way or the other where you get super
militant over things that aren't that
big a deal stuff is triggering you from
your childhood
and where you just kind of let the next
thing go and the next thing go and the
next thing go
right and then it hasn't come out yet
but a show is going to come out
my son is is was with a couple of
friends
in a drive-through a dad took them all
to a baseball game it was incredible
and my son was in a drive-through and he
took him to mcdonald's and then that
night
i didn't know that that night i said hey
man what'd you have for dinner and he
said oh nothing i just had a couple of
french fries
i was like why they didn't y'all didn't
eat i gave you some money
and he said yeah but we went to
mcdonald's and i just
i told him i just couldn't support that
and i was like
dude have a burger man you're out with
your buddy you know what i mean and so
that told me
i i've hit the pendulum too far right
that's that's crazy
and so all that to say is that's my
stuff that now i'm passing along to him
right
right and so it's just finding that
sweet balance i think the most important
thing is to have that conversation with
your husband
with yourself with a counselor outside
of this home so you know where your
boundaries are
and then no uh this is what i'm bringing
drama on
to my family that is my own stuff and
this is when i really need to step in
and that line is just unfortunately
different for everybody
yeah but i do love love
love that you're looking out for your
daughter the bigger thing is gonna be
i in my opinion maybe i'm crazy the
bigger the bigger opinion for me is
gonna be media consumption what are
these pictures what are these images
that are gonna communicate to my
daughter what beauty is what beauty is
not
are they going to hear language like oh
that person's less than
that person disgusts me those are the
kind of things that deeply
imprint deeply in wire into a child
right
yeah and those are the things to be
careful of if you hear that kind of
nonsense at a table
that's when um like when you're out to
dinner
i will i will and i have said hey uh
we're not gonna do that
and i've overrode those kind of comments
with family members with people i love
um because they're not trying to be ugly
this just becomes jokes and silly and
we're just being fun i'm just poking
around
and i need everybody to make sure and
i'm communicating my kid
sometimes people are gonna say things
that are going to hurt your feelings or
that are going to
be inappropriate and here's how you
stand up to that gently respectfully but
directly too right
and you're getting free child care i
know that makes this whole thing super
super messy
super messy it's hard to put a price on
your values it's hard to put a price on
your morality and i know that makes this
whole thing so complicated
rest assured you're a good mom i'm so
i'm just proud of you for even having
the thoughts in the conversation
um sometimes self-discipline looks like
smiling and saying thank you and then
put in the trash
that's so messy all right let's take the
next call let's go to jamie in
atlanta hey jamie what's up hey how are
you doing
rocking onto the break of dawn how are
you i'm doing all right
um i'll try to get to the point of my
question it's kind of a long one
i feel like i'm probably dealing with
some postpartum depression
and anxiety and my husband's a
firefighter
paramedic but he works 24-hour shifts
and is gone
um does it every three days so i'm kind
of left with
the two kids and
sometimes i feel like i've just kind of
silently been struggling with it i
haven't really wanted to talk to him
about it because
you know he deals with a lot of stuff
too um
our kids have been constantly sick for
like two months
we're talking you know go into urgent
care at least once a week it feels like
going to the doctor
so things like that so a lot of that's
kind of flowing on me and it's not like
it's his fault or anything like that
it's just it just more so falls on me
um and then here recently um he
ran a very traumatic call that hit very
close to hose
and just as i kind of felt like i was
ready to talk about how i was
kind of drowning you know at home with
the kids he goes through this
and you know i he is always pretty good
about
you know tough calls he can kind of put
it in the back seat if you will he's
followed away
hey jamie talk directly into your
mouthpiece for me oh i'm sorry i'm sorry
perfect um and then this i'm sorry
um and then this call he just
lost it and cried um
i can literally count probably on one
hand the times that i've seen
you know my husband cry yeah so
yeah um so and i want to give away too
much
that's great it's just very yeah so when
you say that you
think you are struggling from postpartum
what makes you think that
because you pain here's the deal you may
very well be you just painted me a
picture
of a totally normal
completely fried and exhausted mom
and wife of a first responder
which is very very lonely
and very exhausting and then you throw
in the pandemic
and and and and and er trips and i'm
cooked
so all of that if you're at a point
where you
feel like you were standing over the
precipice of a big giant hole i would
tell you
exactly where you need to be like that
makes sense to me um
but you may also have postpartum on top
of this tell me about that
well i mean my baby was born in the
height
of the pandemic last year um
to the point where i almost didn't have
my husband there for delivery
um so he's he's a year old now so
i mean i don't know if it still could be
postpartum i know he's you know they say
it's usually like birth to a year
old um but it's i mean i don't know it's
just
just some days i listen to another
podcast
girl saying like sometimes you just
don't even like your kids and that's
kind of where i feel like
i'm at because they're so ex it's just
so exhausting to have everything just
come at you
you know left and right i know a lot of
people
my age who don't like their kids they
love them but there's just seasons where
it's like whoa
um can you please stay well you know
yes all right here's what i want to do i
just want to get up and go to the
bathroom
in a room alone and not have a trail of
little ducklings be like mom hey mom mom
or just scream right that so they follow
you
oh my gosh yes everywhere and that's me
projecting on
to being a new mom i don't know what
that's like i know when i just get home
they follow me around and it's like two
hours a day much less
right so um so here's the thing
i i don't know if i've got more personal
experience
slash professional experience in this
one issue this one thing
then what i'm gonna describe to you
right now okay
when you are married to somebody when
you're in a relationship with somebody
and you are struggling and they
have a profession whether it's a doctor
a lawyer
a preacher a first responder a cop
the an hr director these day a teacher
and you know they are going through hard
things
what makes sense logically
is that i'm gonna shield my stuff from
them
because i know they're having a hard
time and i don't want to burden them
with my stuff because they're having a
hard time
and so what happens is and this is this
happens all the time
spouses end up drowning because they
don't want to wave their hand in the air
and let somebody know that they're
they can't touch and they're in the
water right
and here's what happens the spouse is
also drowning
because it's not about the um
it's not about the shared burden issue
it's about the connection issue
and so when you see a first responder
get home and they just collapse in tears
and you go whoa it's easy to see that as
oh they're carrying so much trauma
seeing so much trauma
that i can't tell them that i'm drowning
too
and what i would suggest is they are
they the cure for trauma is connection
and so there's a difference between
using each other as
dumpsters right as trash bins you're not
gonna believe what happened today
yeah and there is something really
valuable
about saying i am really hurting how are
you
right not that you're going to solve
each other's problems and what first
responders especially firemen ems and
cops
they get home i say that doctors and
lawyers do too they get home
and then wife you know i'm just
generalizing this
wife says hey billy and tommy were the
worst today
well you're not asking for what to how
to solve that
you're just trying to connect with
somebody and they respond with well you
should have done this and this and right
in the because they know how to solve
problems that's what they do all day
and then you end up further apart than
you started right
yeah so here's what i hear i hear two
people
desperate to reconnect
two little kids will drive a wedge in
the tightest of relationships just
because two little kids crap everywhere
and they yell all the time and they
don't sleep right
and taking kids in and out of the er all
by yourself
is a wedge between two people i don't
care how tight you are and
dealing with death and regimen
and burning homes and car wrecks after
another after another
that'll drive a wedge between people and
so
when you've got little kids you have to
be hyper intentional
about connection when you work a job
where you are
dealing with secondary traumatic stress
other people's drama other people's
trauma
for a living you got to be hyper
intentional about connection
here's what that looks like in real time
okay jamie it looks like
him coming home and not telling you
about
blood and guts that's not it it's him
coming home
and having 10 minutes to hold your hands
and look you in the eye and say
whoo i saw some stuff that i shouldn't
have seen today really hard
and you holding him looking him in the
eye saying
tell me about how that feels in your
body and him being able to say
well i don't know if i can breathe and
him being able to ex
cycle through that experience with you
not with blood and guts not oh my gosh
my boss
but hey i s like man i really had a hard
day at work my boss said some stuff that
got in my soul
and instead of you going well you should
have said this and you say
hey tell me where that's showing up in
your body how does that feel
in him going to my guts right or it's in
my chest i can't breathe
whatever that feels like and then you
being able to say and being able to look
at you and go
you look like you got hit by a bus
you're still beautiful and pretty but
whoa you look like you're carrying a lot
and you say
yeah um today was a really hard day with
the kids it was hard
um and you being able to talk about what
your experience was not
and then and then oh my gosh and there
was poop and
but it's just being able to say it was
so hard right and so you're
looking at places you can have
connection and so
here's what i'll tell you here's how
i've seen it happen here's how i've done
it and i haven't
i've done it terrible in my house like
what you're explaining to me
i've been through in my home okay
this is hard very quickly
the i don't want to talk to him about it
because i don't want to burden him
you know what that becomes a secret
i'm just going to hold on to this and
then very quickly that secret becomes
are you doing all right yeah i'm fine
and you know what that is that's a lie
it's not true
and now all of a sudden i've got
deception between me and my wife
and then that's kind of where i'm at
yeah yeah and so you know what's going
to happen here
is you're going to find yourself mad
that you're having to lie
and you're going to blame him for that
madness
and then i don't care who you are i
don't care what situat
you will find connection somewhere else
period
our brains are it's too it drives every
function of our bodies our heart rates
our brains it it drives
everything and you might find connection
through
gardening or making a list or find
connection through
some social causes or your church or you
will find it somewhere else
that's also where you find it with
another drink and another drink and a
drink
or some guy who is picking up their kid
and just
says man you are awesome right and
suddenly it's like oh i haven't had
anybody tell me i'm awesome
right it happened so in inconspicuously
right and so and happens vice versa here
on the other side too
double back down on that connection
right this is one of those moments where
we have
i feel like am i reading your mail here
kind of
yeah you're getting quieter and quieter
i know i'm talking a lot no
so here's what i got as i'm telling you
you're
and i'm telling everybody listening you
don't protect the person you love
by shutting them off you don't protect
the person you love by keeping secrets
you do protect them by the details
by the blood and the guts right and the
color of poop on your shirt
that's not always helpful right um
you don't protect them by keeping
secrets and secrets just
end in ash every time or they
end in 40 year olds uh roommates
right where you have separate parallel
lives so here's the thing
find a babysitter find one of his 24
cycles off and i want you all to go out
to breakfast somewhere together
and just exhale and tell him hey i miss
you
and i know you miss me and we are
starting to drift
and we're going to do whatever it takes
to double back and it's probably going
to mean you all need to go see a
marriage counselor not because your
marriage is in jeopardy although it
might be i don't know
but you're probably going to need to go
see somebody to learn some tools
and first responders are the best
at first responding they are not always
the best at learning
how to connect relationally because they
have to disconnect that part of their
brain to respond to blood and guts
every night every night every night but
that sort of response doesn't work
inside a home
so go talk to a counselor go talk to a
pastor but look your husband eye and say
hey i feel like we're drifting and we're
not gonna do this
because you mean everything to me and
he's going to look at you and say you
mean everything to me
and we're going to double down on
reconnecting what i promise you
jamie i promise you if you make
reconnection your priority it'll send
you both on a journey
but man your marriage will be stronger
and more incredible
you gotta you've heard me say this a
million times you gotta clear the deck
you gotta burn
not burn but you gotta sweep excavate
all of the old building out
you got two kids you're exhausted
you gotta build something new build it
intentionally together and then man
that foundation is so strong ain't
nothing going to shake that
that's a lie something will shake it big
time and then you may have to
knock it down and rebuild something else
but you're going to keep doing it
together and together because you're
doubling
down on that connection
and back to the postpartum if you
are worried that you are thinking about
hurting yourself
worry about hurting somebody else you
are going for days on end without
sleeping you are going for days on end
with
that rattling in your bones call your
doctor don't hesitate to do
right postpartum is real it's terrifying
it is disconnecting for everybody call
your doctor if you're worried about
postpartum
okay thank you so much for your call
jamie oh
man what a blessing appreciate you so
much hey we'll take a quick break we'll
be right back on the dr john daloni show
hey what's up i want to take a quick
break to talk about the most important
question i'm asked almost every day
how do i find a counselor if you can't
find a counselor in your area
or you can't afford one i've got a
solution for you
i've partnered with a better help for
customized online therapy
video chat text chat phone counseling
it's a licensed therapist whenever and
wherever you
need them go to betterhelp.com deloney
for 10 off your first month it's cheaper
and it's available
all the time this is for you your family
and for everyone else that's coming your
way
take care of your mental health go to
betterhelp.com deloney today
all right we are back hey listen i've
got an email yeah i always say hey
listen
you're literally sitting there with
headphones in your head
or you're driving down the road or
you've got the
youtubes on in the corner you already
are listening so when somebody says hey
listen and you're already listening i
realize that's
annoying so sorry about that so
we've got an email here that i want to
touch on because i love this question
it's from this guy named james it's
probably not from james childs even
though maybe
he knows that guy says
what is the difference between a
boundary and an ultimatum
i've heard you talk about both of them
but i can't figure out the difference
seems like one is good and one is bad
can you clarify
that's an awesome question
here's how i would define boundary
versus ultimatum
and they they come down to the purpose
of each one
a boundary is a way i am seeking
connection
in a healthy way it is me saying hey i
would like to remain in relationship
with you
i would like to continue to work here i
would like to
um have a healthy relationship with you
and here is what i need
to stay whole and well so my boundary is
i go to bed at ten o'clock if we're
gonna do crazy fun things if we're gonna
have this rambunctious sex life
awesome it's gotta happen before then
because
if i don't go to bed by 10 then i've got
to get up at five to take care of the
kids to do x and y and z
then it's going to cause challenges or
hey listen i want to work here but you
can't talk to me like that
that's a boundary right this is what i
need to be healthy here
ultimatum i i consider ultimatum
the the the line in the sand
right it's a power move it's not a it's
it's not a way we're gonna it's not me
trying to reach out and remain connected
to you
it is me saying no more
or i will scorch the earth around us
right so an
ultimatum is if you cross this line
this is when i disconnect from you so an
ultimatum is a statement of
disconnection
this is it no more a boundary
is this is what i need to be well so one
is is me
communicating with you hey this is what
i need for us to stay connected
and the other one is this is the line i
draw you cross this line and we are
disconnected
and i know they sound that's like you
just said the same thing
backwards think of them on so
beat up on this word right now but think
of those on a spectrum a boundary
is a conversation about how i'm going to
remain healthy in this relationship
an ultimatum says here is the line and
if you crosses this relationship is over
i'm done i'm out i'm moving out i'm
finished
i quit right those are the difference
there one of them is
seeking connection one of them is about
power
one of them says enough so
is one good and one bad i don't know
because if
if if i'm in an abusive relationship and
i say
no more that's my ultimatum if this
happens again i'm gone
i think that's a good thing i think
that's you need to exert power in that
situation
um if you so i
i think it's all contextual right so i i
hesitate to say one's good and what's
bad
they're just you use them in differently
in different situations when you find
yourself in a work environment
does it begin to take your soul from you
begin to look back step back and say
here's what i need to work here
hey i'm not gonna go to war with you
boss
but if you need me to be here 24 7 365
i i can't i can't do that so i i wish
you the best of luck i'm gonna go find
me another job
right am i gonna hate you am i gonna say
mean things about you in the internet
but i'm gonna go find another job
right um or in a relationship hey look
um you keep coming home at midnight
you're not texting or calling
like man that makes me feel not safe
that makes me feel like you've got
more other priorities that aren't me
here's what i need to feel safe in this
relationship i need you to at least let
me know
i need you to let me know where you are
i need you to let me know if you're
going to stand me up on a date
that's different then if you stand me up
again this is over
boundaries versus ultimatum so great
question james i hope that helped
um hey and so instead of taking one more
call we're going to do something special
today
i'm going to take advantage of the one
and only bob marquez
every show we end with the greatest song
of all time
but you have to listen to my whiny
rambly tinny voice
now we've got the voice of a
professional of
a true master craftsman so bob
said hey he's got some bob you got some
poetry for us i have some poetry for you
a song so this is this greatest song of
all time of all the songs
ever in history you picked this one
i did here we go you can't touch this
you can't touch this you can't touch
this
you can't touch this my my
my my music hits me so hard makes me say
oh my lord
thank you for blessing me with a mind to
rhyme and a two-hyped feet
feels good when you know you're down a
super dope homebody from the oaktown
and i'm known as such and this is a beat
you can't
yes thanks for bringing us poetry mc
hammer you can't touch this right
here on the dr john dolone show
you